okay good morning and welcome back
the first speaker in this parallel
session is Sergey Boyko
and he will tell us about characterizing
quantum supremacy near-term devices
thank you so first of all quantum
superposition name but it may be a
little bit too edgy so sometimes I like
to call it beyond classical computing
and I if it's gonna catch on maybe
somebody can come up with a better name
but let me start with motivating why
we're thinking about this so this
photograph right here is the current
state of the art at the Google hardware
group is by Yo Martinez so this group is
working in superconducting qubits high
fidelity superconducting qubits Axman
qubits what you see here is these are
the cubed six months there you have I
think six of them these are they read at
resonators this is a 1d layout of qubits
and one thing that is very nice and is
currently working for us but they are
making very good progress is there is
this other chip that is gonna come on
top of this and this chip is going to
have the control lines microwave lines
see pulses to control these qubits so
you're going to be able to separate the
control from the qubits themselves the
qubits can remain very coherent and one
important reason to do it this way I
have one tip of on top of the other with
bonbons superconducting bonbons that
connect the control lines here with your
qubits there is that this will allow us
to do a to the layout of superconducting
qubits are we talking about circuits I'm
thinking in superconducting qubits it
will be something else which live in a
2d grid with nearest neighbors coupling
we think that maybe this year or next
year we'll see we're going to be able to
have a layout of 7 by 7 high fidelity
superconducting qubits so that's the
motivation for this work
and so the question is what to do with
these devices so what we have been
thinking about we and other people is we
would like to perform a well-defined
computational task this is very
important we want to write down in a
piece of paper what particular
computation we're trying to do very
explicitly and the important thing which
is what this talk is about is this
computational task with seven by seven
cubits we think can be already beyond
the capabilities of a state-of-the-art
supercomputers and that's what we call
video classical computing or else or
quantum supremacist introduced by young
per scale in this paper now what is
important to have in mind is we're kind
of practical we're thinking we want to
these when we have the chip available
maybe this year next year so this is
gonna be done in the near term we're not
gonna have our correction and therefore
we're gonna be limited to silo circuits
with high fidelity gates so there is a
lot of work because you know for a long
time with superconducting qubits simply
improving the fidelity's now you get
Fidelity's of at least nine is for to
give it gates and around three nines for
single qubit gates so that's what we're
gonna get so that's what we're thinking
about now there is a catch here we are
not necessarily solving a practical
problem and as a matter of fast in the
stuff we're talking about it's going to
be a well-defined operational task but
it doesn't solve a practical problem
that people necessarily curse about and
I will say this a very big open question
that I would like help people to think
about I know you're aware of these what
can we do with our ones you have these
chips what can you do with shallow
circuits without error correction and
the important thing that makes this
problem interesting is that at least we
believe we're going to be able to solve
fairly convincingly that we're going to
have a computational resource for some
problems already beyond the capabilities
of supercomputers okay
so if you want to do you want to do this
billion classical computing or content
supremacy in the near term
what what kind of products have we think
about well quantum computers and these
superconducting qubits in particular
they are very good doing quantum
evolutions so to make the problem harder
for the classical supercomputers we want
to formalize some additional tasks which
we think requires the direct simulation
of the quantum evolution to be solved by
a classical computer the only way the
classical computer conserve the same
task is some form of direct simulation
why want to have that well it's because
the direct simulation of quantum
dynamics for enough depth is going to be
the cost is going to be exponential in
the number of qubits so we have 7 by 7
grid that's exponential in 2 to the 49
which is a very large number so some
physicists like to think of these as
typical characteristic of Kotik systems
in the sense that if you have a cultic
evolution which is very sensitive to the
specific parameters which are going to
be well specify because this is a formal
conditional problem then the only way to
really get the exact final state of this
chaotic evolution is to simulate
devolution directly because if it's very
chaotic there are no symmetries or
shortcuts that you can exploit to avoid
doing the direct simulation we also want
to have find a specific figure of Merit
for this computational task that tells
us not only what competition we're doing
but how well we're doing that
computation it's actually going to be an
approximate problem so we want to have a
fear of Mary that tells us how how well
we're doing this approximate
computational task and it is suppliers
which is important for us because we're
thinking very hard about the hardware
that these companies this fear of Merit
is related to fidelity so I'll explain
how that goes in our particular case and
something that is very interesting are
probably for folks in this in this
conference is there are interesting
relations to computational complexity so
previous work we're going to be talking
about something progress the previous
works and something progress that a lot
of you are familiar with is about some
sampling and also our commuting circuits
we actually when we talk about
computational complexity which will be
at the end of my talk there are we use
tools for
that were developed for community
circles my brother and collaborators
there is a recent paper with a very
interested in a strong conjecture by our
insulin child which is related to what
we're doing here we say that for a
random three Coetzee with there are some
details how do you actually choose this
one encirclement in a 2d lattice
actually so that's good of devs around
square defend there is no polynomial
time classical algorithms that guesses
the probability if you start with sir
that probably did to misread put all
sorrows such that I knew when I guess if
this probability is larger than the
median overall output beat the strings
and then when the polynomial time
classical are going to guess this
probability with success probability at
least 1/2 plus something which is
potential in the number of qubits
crucially not the number of gates this
can be done there's a polynomial time
algorithm which will guess this with
probability scaling with 1 over 2 to the
number of gates but not 1 over 2 to the
number of qubits that we know of so this
is a very strong conjecture which is
interesting
nevertheless we still have a problem in
terms of computational complexity which
is that computational complexity as
personal synthetic and I would say for
the kind of process we have here what if
a gravitational task where I write
exactly what competition I'm trying to
do as far as I know it requires your
correction so for instance we are not
going to satisfy this conjecture in the
near term because the quantum computer
is also know is going to have a success
probability scaling with the number of
qubits because the fidelity of the gates
are finite so that means the probability
of success is going to decrease with the
number of gates not the number of qubits
so when you don't formally satisfy at
least this conjecture for instance we
saw there correction but this is still
very interesting and gives you stronger
confidence I guess that the classical
competition will scale as potentially in
a number of qubits and therefore you're
going to give classical supercomputers a
hard time so what is the particular
computational task we've been looking at
well the most obvious thing to do I will
say is just do random universal quantum
circuits because these are quantum
dynamics and they are very chaotic in
this
that if you do around them circuit and
you get one get wrong we will talk more
about this later then you're probably
not going to get the correct and put
distribution here so we're just gonna
have a random circuit into the this is
just an example in 1d how we are careful
because we want to do this in the near
term about what choice of gates with n1
how we lay out the gate maybe we'll
become a bit more clear what are our
constraints but let's just say the main
constraint is in this superconducting
qubits at least we have only control
phase gates here control-c gates we
cannot do a control c gate in these two
qubits and these nearest neighbor skills
at the same time there have to be one
gap in the middle for technical reasons
at least at the moment so that means we
have to do some things at the beginning
like we do Halle Mars because the state
tends to let's say scramble faster this
way and I'll be more specific about what
messer are we using two gates that okay
so the particular computation our
problem that we want to solve is a
sampling problem and what we want to do
is given an instance of a random circuit
where it's I'm selecting with some rules
that I'm giving you a universal gate set
and I'm telling you what are you random
probabilities to choose what gates in
this case is basically hollow Marty
gates square root of x and a square root
of Y and then some layout of control-c
gates so the qubits have a chance to
interact and correlations propagate so a
computational problem is to
approximately sample from the output
distribution specify but this circuit or
unitary if I measure in the
computational basis I see this is a
well-defined competition or problem and
we think that the that to solve this
problem you the only way to do it is to
do the red simulation substance or there
are different ways to do that but there
are simulations nevertheless and the
costs we into this will be exponential
in either the minimum of the number of
qubits of the depth times the square
root of n if you use transfer network
infractions so for seven by seven cubits
we think that the boundary if we are
careful enough and you look into the
details of how this thing is going is
there's the around 40 so after d/deaf
theorem 40 we don't think that the short
network contraction will work either and
to 249
just too many qubits to do this
Schrodinger simulation so that's our
current best estimate now this is also a
good benchmark for quantum computers in
the sense that we're doing a random
circuit which is going to create a very
entangle state and if we can estimate
the fidelity with which we're doing this
test that's giving us a good benchmark
for how well we're doing not just single
qubit or two qubit gates but how well
we're doing very complex circuits
pre-primary complex estates and as I
said before this computational task is
related to results in computational
complexity and I will talk about that a
bit more later so this is known about
random circuits because they are cutting
evolutions but you basically are going
to prepare some quantum states I given
by some amplitude C on the computational
basis we care about the probabilities of
with the strings which are of course the
square of the amplitude and what you can
think is that you're going to be not
uniformly distributed in Kilvert the
space but more or less you know quasi
uniformly these three - the hilbert
space so that means that up to finite
moments not a moment's but up to five at
moments the distribution of this
amplitudes will be Gaussian with mean
zero and variance manoharan
and if the amplitudes are Gaussian that
implies that the distribution of the
probabilities if I normalize it like
this with these large n is 1 over 2 to
the N so this over the space that's what
we report our distribution the porter
thomas distribution has been around
since the 50s related to chaos actually
which has this particular formula so we
think that there are probabilities will
be porter thomas distributed and not
uniform between bitter strings 1 over n
ok so there is a problem with that
because this is a very fluid
distribution right so unfortunately we
don't know of any polynomial witness so
it's hard to verify this circuit because
we don't know how to check in a black
box setting let's say with a polynomial
amount of classical resources that we're
doing the correct computation so that's
a problem and but I think this is
probably required because we're doing
the sampling problem which is much
harder than NP problems in the sense
that yeah this will collapse the
polynomial her confusion
but you know the PT distribution in the
partner Thomas distribution is very flat
so the probabilities they can decay
exponentially with - and P so they're
gonna be on the order of 1 over N so in
a black mark ii that's a problem because
just distinguish this porter thomas
distribution with uniform flat
distribution over beta strings it
requires of the order of the square root
of n measurements which might be doable
it's not crazy to to the 20 measurements
but still all you're doing is this thing
was important for mass or some
approximate porter thomas from uniform
so one saving grace we're gonna use to
try to gauge that were on the right
track at least is we're gonna do that
even though this is really flat if you
look at the l1 distance between the
porter thomas distribution and let's say
the uniform distribution related swings
it's actually pretty large with this
normalization is between 3 & 2 so it's 2
2 2 is a finite and one norm independent
of the number of qubits so that means
that information theoretic lee and in
particular if we calculate these
probabilities pxj which we can do
probably not 449 cubits and the 40 but
for let's say 42 cubed some whatever
depth then we can actually distinguish
between the porter thomas distribution
and the uniform distribution and I'll be
more specific or rather something more
sophisticated on this but this is a form
of our verification if assess that you
have too much noise
yes past two converts the uniform
distribution verbally strings okay so so
we think we should be getting the porter
thomas distribution with enough depth so
for this particular layout of circuit
which is very specific given the
concrete Harbor constraints of the
qubits we care about because that's the
ones we have in our particular lab other
people might have different specifics of
a delay out of this of their circuits we
care about how fast we converts to the
porter thomas distribution and we
actually want thing we care about is how
FAR's would emerge to the correct
entropy from the porter thomas
distribution which is different from the
entropy of the uniform distribution so
as this plot here we see as a function
of depth with circuits rise 7 7 x 68 so
42 Q is this is a very expensive
simulation done by mrs. Polanski from
Intel we care like what the f do you
require to approximate the correct
entropy and we see only a depth 15 or
around 20 your
very close actually yes potentially
close at depth 30 to the correct porter
thomas estimation this is for seven
sorry six by six another way to check
that your that you are getting close to
the porter thomas distribution is to
check not the entropy at the moment so
we took the moments this is related to
the size in condensed matter they call
them participation ratios are inverse
participation ratios we see that but the
second moment that converts very quickly
to porter thomas but actually higher
moments i'm normalizing these moments so
for the porter thomas distribution
they're on one so up to a moment n for
instance a finite amount of moments they
converts quickly to a porter thomas
distribution sorta for the same depth
and they all seem to converts well all i
mean let's say moments of where there
may be and we don't exactly know what we
think around order and they come back to
porter thomas not an exponential amount
of moments of course but the first
moments at least the compares to the
porter thomas distribution really
quickly there's a lot of interesting
theory work related to the death
requires to sort of prepare this very
complex estate which is what we're
getting with this porter thomas
distribution for instance with the
complaining random circuits or on the
concentration of esparza QP circuits is
known that the dev requires quails like
a square root of n for a square root of
n by square root of n cubed so in cubed
Sina to the lattice and of to knowledge
make corrections and respect these two
whole also for two designs for entropy
out of time more their correlations
things like that okay so we say we have
a porter thomas distribution and what is
the computational task we do well we
want to sample from the porter thomas
distribution so let's take a sample of
around am bitstrings experimental ii
with superconducting qubits m can be
close to million let's say in will take
order of seconds so we have her on a
million samples of random ET strings I'm
going to check what's the likelihood
that this sample came from the
particular unitary that I'm trying to
implement right because my computational
task is to sample from the product
distribution specifically this unitary
so let's check the likelihood and
actually the log likelihood of a
particular sample that I have time
right so if everything is if it was
ideal if there was no noise then they're
not likelihood is proportional to the
entropy of the porter thomas
distribution and entropy of the porter
thomas distribution you can just
calculate that and is not the entropy of
the uniform distribution but there is
this minus 1 plus gamma correction which
is independent of the number of qubits
where gamma is the Euler constant so
that tells you what kind of likelihood
you will get 4 samples in 88 cakes now
if you have a classical polynomial time
algorithm which would be like your
classical competition that you want to
run well you can also take some sample
of the same size and now you're going to
be looking at the likelihood that that
sample from a classical algorithm the
likelihood that that sample could have
been produced by the circuit that you
specified so how well it matches your
computational task and the lot
likelihood is now not given by the
entropy but is going is given by the
cross entropy which is this expression
so it's not P of X is P sin of X but
this is P you because I'm checking the
likelihood that it came from the ideal
circuit so the log likelihood in this
case is proportional to the cross
entropy so let's look at this cross
entropy and actually let's look at the
cross entropy when I average our circuit
so the comte tional task of course is
not just for one instance to be able to
the sum presumably something from one
particular instance but if I do this
hundred times let's say with different
random instances of random circuits and
it examples of a million samples in each
case then I want to look at this
petition value of these cross entropy
average over circuits over unit area so
I want to look at this expression so now
I'm gonna make an answer so this is just
an answer at this stage it's kind of
related to Scott's conjecture but it is
an on-set that if this is a polynomial
algorithm given that you know this is a
very hard mutational task that requires
to do direct simulation of the dynamics
and you can expect to have a polynomial
algorithm to do this task so then they
sampling from the polynomial classical
algorithms will be uncorrelated more or
less with the
correct distribution as specified in the
circuit because the current distribution
requires exponential time so if we
calculate the cross entropy assuming
that this classical distribution is
uncorrelated with the distribution and
we are three circuits then we get an
expression which is log n plus gamma
which is different to the entropy for
the correct order from a distribution
which was log n plus gamma minus 1 so
there is a difference in the entropy and
the cross entropy so here are some
numeric sort of to support this
conjecture so what we do here is for
circuits of the 25 5 times 4 cubed
actually sorry depth 40 let's say we
simulate the correct circuit which you
know sunny 20 cubits we can do and we
also drop let's say in this case B to
the power X are in every possible place
okay discrete X are and we see that the
distribution in that case and now we
calculate the correlation between the
correct distribution and the
distribution with one single error and
we see that they are almost uncorrelated
so this is depth where I dropped my
error the color is like over the 20
different locations at the depth and
this axis here is correlation and you
see if I drop an error in the middle
I'm almost uncorrelated support in that
conjecture if you drop a lecture at the
beginning well we started with a llamar
so it gets absorbed in the
initialization and something similar
happens with sears is that that we're
going to be measuring the conditional
basis so I were studying as observed in
the measurement so during most of
evolution one discrete error breaks the
correlation which kind of supports this
conjecture so let's move on we saw there
was a difference between the cross
entropy if the distributions were
uncorrelated severe least reason and
distribution that I used to take the
sample we're gonna call that H sub
nought and I was log n plus gamma and so
for any algorithm quantum experimental
circuit let's say or a classical
algorithm we're gonna look at the cross
entropy now between that the
distribution for this meta-data
algorithm and ideal distribution and
we're gonna compare it with the worst
case which was an uncorrelated output
which of course you can always
and if we look at this course entropy
difference so what's the difference
within the worst case on what we're
actually doing we call it alpha well
let's see what happens in this course
entropy in the particular case that the
algorithm is a noisy random circuit
which is what we're going to get
experimentally so we can we're going to
break that put distribution like this
which we cannot always do but
approximately we think this is correct
so we're gonna say it's gonna be some
alpha tilde times the ideal circuit plus
1 minus alpha tilde some density matrix
that accumulates all the noise this
alpha tilde is the fidelity and again
similar as before we're gonna assume
that because we saw that any single disc
read error completely given uncorrelated
distribution almost every worse that
davina there and we're gonna assume that
if you sample from this part of the
operator which emulates there you're
going to be almost related with the
current distribution so if we use the
Sun set this is again another ancestor
then we can work out this cross entropy
difference alpha as the difference
between the worst case cross entropy and
the cross entropy when my distribution
has this density matrix and in a couple
of steps again that the difference
between the cross entropy is
approximately the fidelity of a tilde so
this is good because my figure I've made
for this computational task which is
alpha so this will give me if I can
calculate it and I will talk about how
you can calculate later for small enough
circuits so give me an estimation of the
fidelity which we care about because
when I check the hardware okay so let's
check this sunset we have been doing
with Sun numerix to see if things make
sense so with the numerix where we
calculate the cross entropy we drop in
the stand away depolarization channels
with error rates are that are related to
realistic figures of Merit for fidelity
in superconducting qubits or there
is up the small correction is the
fidelity so these numbers here are the
rates for two qubit gates the control
faces that we have in experiment
experimental II where more or less
around here we want to be between here
here I guess and we assume the single
qubit gates to have a fidelity tenten's
best initialization a measurement to
have error rates of the order of the two
qubit gates so this is reasonable were
using a very simple model though but it
it's been much in much as well
experiments that have been done before
so assuming that this our model works
well we just to the numerix so we we we
simulate the circuit with this
declaration channels we calculate the
cross entropy so those are the squares
for different neural rates and we
calculate and very crude estimate which
will be in the next slide just the
product of the Fidelity's so we estimate
the fidelity as the product of the
fidelity of the different gates and we
see that more or less this cross entropy
corresponds to the estimate of the
fidelity is a bit higher probably
because errors at the beginning and at
the end get absorb in initialization or
measurement but they do accept the view
affect the fidelity okay so what is the
actual experimental proposal well we
want to implement a random Universal
circuit and we have some specific rules
of what circuits we care about and we're
going to take a large sample
experimentally over a million
measurements seventeen a thousand and a
million and then and this is a tricky
part at least if the circuit is not
large enough
sorry it's not very large so let's say
42 qubits or it doesn't have a lot of
depth or a ciggy bravi will display next
it doesn't have a lot of T gates
independent of the depth and the size
then we should be able to calculate with
a classical computer these probabilities
so they these be the string came from
the experiment and with a classical
computer not with the quantum computer
here so calculate the log of the
probability that that particularly the
swing came from the current distribution
the ideal distribution if I average
these quantities over my measurements
and I've normalized properly with this
gamma this gives me an estimate of the
cross-entropy
alpha up to Corrections which go like 1
over the square root of the number of
measurements so for a million
measurements this is not our biggest
concern and as we explained before we
think that this percent rupee will give
us an estimate of the actual fidelity of
the preparation so the plan is to
measure this when we can so for size
let's say up to 42 for depth of 2 let's
say 20 25 with 49 cubits you know with
their deaths 40 M 49 cubits but only
like 50 ta it's more or less and so then
then we can actually measure this and
then we're going to separate on this
plot in sort of different access is this
croissant rope is all much the fidelity
estimate so here is the fidelity
estimate from just multiplying the
fidelity's and if all these works then
we have confidence that the hardware is
working so it's really just pretty fine
that the hardware is working when we can
test that so you should also be working
if now I put a few more tickets or I
make it a bit bigger or something like
that
and at some point we cannot verify it
anymore unfortunately but it's still be
doing some approximate sampling with
some fidelity that as far as we know a
classical supercomputer can not much and
that's what we call beyond classical
computing okay so I said their works
that were interesting relations between
these and complexity theory so here is
one approach so if you have super
interests on the square of this
amplitude so let's just think about this
amplitude I start in ass tits Errol I do
my Unitarian shortcut and I want to
estimate calculate the amplitude for
output be the string X so this is a
well-known trick if you do you have
levels clock cycles in this 2d circuit
so at every one of these levels you can
introduce an identity which we're going
to call else because we're going to
think of them as pins in a basis plus
minus 1 that's fine is just what you
call your basis and then we basically
have to multiply all the levels over all
possible beta 3
which are the complexions of the
identity in the middle so this looks
like if you want some sort of discrete
path internal right where I'm swimming
over all the paths and the paths are
specified by these beater swings that
you're putting in the meal like that
rotary station in passenger Monte Carlo
that was discussed in some other talks
okay so this is this press in that we
care about well it true so that if I
look at one of these pieces for our
particular gates like a square root of x
ray instance then you can actually write
it because I'm using this pin basis as
something that looks like a nice in
model okay
so I have this interaction between spins
and K is the clock cycles if I put a
square root of x it can flip the spin so
this is an interaction between a spin
and one clock cycle and another spin the
time I get in the next clock cycle this
number here of the case one if I have a
birth of X in that particular cycle Sara
in other cases we only get this
interaction if I actually had the square
root of x and there is a face in front
of it and the same holds for t gates
which are actually simpler because it's
just a face in these bases or square
root of Y or control-c gates so the
conclusion is that you can write this
expression okay as an exponential of
expressions that look like this so an
exponential of something that looks like
an icy model with some complex face in
front of it and if you do that they are
right in this expression your some
mineral bit strange we are writing this
expression something proportional to the
partition function of the xix model at
complex temperature so these random
circuits have probabilities that are
proportional to the partition function
square now of icy models add some
complex temperature in this case PI
right now there is a very if you want to
calculate this partition function sort
of approximately there is very strong
same problem because you have only a
finite number of phases because all
these numbers are sort of discrete and
but the path corresponding to the river
face
Sarris potentially large in the number
of gates compared to the value of the
partition Francis is a very strong same
problem what is more this is known to be
in the worst case it's known to be pro
listicle e so the complexity of fraud is
the approximate in this partition
function even if you have an empirical
is still Sarpy higher even with an
empirical so here's a reference about
that
so Mira Mira and collaborators made
recently a conjecture that these calls
not only in the worst case but sort of
an average case for some fraction of
partition functions if you select these
participants randomly and in our paper
we say what's the distribution of
couplings and things like that so if you
will have this conjecture then what the
proof in this paper and we just adapt
that is that now with an icing problem
which is slightly different to the one
in the paper then you shouldn't be able
to sample because if you were able to
sample then you can use an empirical to
approximate these parties and falses
which you're assuming is np-hard
so in other ways we just used the same
technique and in this paper to argue
that approximately sampling an algorithm
double approximately sample from this
distribution will collapse the
polynomial rack that's sort of the
technical term based on this particular
collector with a slightly different
Ising models there are 3d models in our
case now this you know there is this new
conjecture right Scott which is very
strongly interest in this alternative
way also gives another interesting
perspective which is it connects IC
models so for instance in this paper
actually they saw that for some
particular complex temperature or faces
you can actually solve this IC models
and it turns out that corresponds to
cliff or gates so just to say it's
interesting to think about these
problems from this different perspective
in terms of pricing models not just
circuits and you can prove certain
things ok so I'm almost done this is
just to give you an idea of how hard it
is to do the simulation in practice
these are numbers from mrs. Polanski
from Intel who run these very large 7x6
simulations under this supercomputer and
you see well that the memory is gaseous
potentially
but Lee Nieman foresees 7x6 circus you
needed 70 terabytes of memory and around
half of the nodes in the Edison
supercomputer and it took like around a
thousand seconds this even at seven by
six with what I think is very optimal
code some people might think they can do
better and that may be true but this
code is a very decent you know it's
performant aright
so it is very expensive to do these
simulations even by seven seven by six
so you know as you grow somebody has to
let you use a full supercomputer for
quite a long time as far as we know okay
so some open questions
the main one with submission in the
beginning this is not a practical
competition is just something from a
random circuit so the main open question
I thing is what can we do which is not
just a random permutation so something
of practical value so people are
thinking about quantum chemistry or
approximate optimization for instance so
I encourage you to give different other
alternatives but details matters we
really have to be careful about how many
gates you have things like that and you
know they're things well you might want
to have experimental proof of our
correction that's not related to these
but something you will do with a small
circuit of course just proof that you're
getting all the correct constants for
this reference code for instance
eventually again as you scale a number
of queries you're gonna have control
problems and deal with has managed this
of that in a different you know
architecture but that's a problem
you know it's scale 2,000 cubits you
don't want to have two thousand wires
you want to prove the fidelity of course
as much as possible this resolved I said
doesn't work with realistic errors so it
will be very good to have complexity
theory results for these random circuits
with full arc without full error
correction improved some bounds into
these so it's the concentration or T
designs and you know we're still working
on optimal classical simulation
algorithms to know exactly where the
competition lies I'll just leave my
conclusions there and I'll take some
questions thank you thank you very much
we have time for a couple of questions
serger so I have a very kind of general
question in in your view is this
pharmacy pharmacy business more a theory
or an experimental challenge and like in
particular do you think that states that
see a chief quantum supremacy in a very
controlled way have been achieved saying
optical lattice when you quench the
system maybe an experiment of talents
yeah my question is whether the main
challenge is experimental or theoretic
from my point of view them in challenge
is experimental ok so you don't think
that states that achieve quorum
supremacy in a control way have already
been produced in other experiments and
I'm okay I don't think I don't think
they have been produced for the case
where you specify very clearly what is
the exact computational does that are
trying to solve and what is the fear of
right but like an optical lattice we
know exactly what the Hamiltonian is you
can quench it there's some complicated
dynamics I can't predict that yeah so
you have to write in a piece of paper
what are you complicated data makes what
is your figure of Merit I mess with the
sphere America so that's a theory
challenge right I think that's right
yeah I think that's up yeah I think
that's a huge challenge but you know
optical lattices my bidders in that
sense if they do that if they write like
this is mike winston Amex this is how I
measure my fidelity they might if
content supremacy or aversive conducive
remedy sooner people might say that you
know the device simulate in itself is
not universal circuits so there will be
some debate there but I think it will be
a very interesting experiment
nevertheless yes but I do care a lot
about you know writing a piece of paper
what is the computation otherwise you
know dear wife is doing computations
that were not sure hard to reproduce
right maybe noise my beliefs may be that
I mean have they achieved Quantrill
supremacy well in my view I mean I'm I
like the away from the things they are
doing but I think you'd really need to
be very formal about what
civic problem you're solving oh how you
miss Rekha Thanks okay
more questions question here it seems to
mean I may be misinterpreting this that
when using a random quantum circuit
you're actually comparing average case
quantum complexity to worst case
classical complexity you mentioned some
boundaries that you're working in where
you have a you're restricting yourself
to a number of T gates per circuit but
is there any kind of like boundary
conditions you guys are looking at
what's the worst possible circuit for
the quantum case and comparing that to
the classical instead of a random
circuit I mean that's right I mean I
have some presence here in your question
but I think you said you're asking like
if we have been a stunning as you
increase the error rate for instance
like a good point you can simulate the
circuit well with the with the random
circuit yeah on the quantum ship it
seems like that's the average case it's
not the worst case possibility first
circuit is there some boundary
conditions that you guys are testing to
put the worst possible circuit on the
quantum ship and comparing that to the
classical counterpart so the worst
possible circuit in the quantum case the
most difficult case on the quantum ship
the most number of gates of completely
saturated circuit or I'm not really sure
what that constitutes on your chip well
we say these random circuits are sort of
the worst case but I'm not sure if I
understood your question because I'm
sorry maybe there can be taken offline
time for one more question and could a
next speaker please set up the computer
in the mean time so maybe it'll just
continue the same line
a lot of ok so I have considered as a
setup so you have to do lightest right
so you can randomly sit out like czg is
basically right and you have some noise
and so the question is what is known for
average case hardness of this problem
because I know results you know there's
like if there is noise or something
known on average case sorry I think
you're very welcome to just say one
sentence that maybe I can understand I
want to know what's known about hardness
of average case under three
circumstances you have noise you have
two DS geometry our guesses took a
circumstance so nice plus 2d geometry
what's and you do average kind of random
circuit noise yes so what's know about
hardness of this from well I think this
I could be sure because there is an
interesting paper with some amount of
noise I think food is going to talk
about also circuits with noise I think
in random circuits in particular for you
know like this is the sort of ideal
circuit that I want you to solve and
then you're kind of approximately sample
once you put noise my intuition is that
as long as you can measure this person
through p4 alerts well okay yeah but you
cannot measure it yeah I don't know
what's the average complexity I think it
discuss with the number of gate we know
that right because you can do these fine
men pass you know integral approach and
then you can get an approximation but I
don't think these lines cross I think
the Fidelity's are high enough that in
the foreseeable future no approximation
algorithm that we can think of actually
can sample with the same you know
process entropy as the noisy quantum
circle once you go beyond what you can
do with excess records I think our
approximate records
scale much worse than high fidelity to
these records but I don't know I don't
know
he'snot theorem to prove that as far as
I can tell okay thank you let's thanks
are here again
[Applause]